blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
okay so i'm gonna be upfront with
everybody there is
a bunch of trump stuff to catch up on in
today's show
i don't even want to wait to get into it
because this past weekend has confirmed
beyond any doubt
trump is in for 2022 and if he succeeds
at getting his friends elected trump is
in for 2024 this weekend donald trump
gave
a major public speech at a republican
event
and published a recorded video message
in which he says
some completely outrageous things which
we are going to get to
and the complete uh totality of the
republican
base is deferring to donald trump now i
know mitt romney isn't okay mitt
romney's not
liz cheney is not deferring to trump
fine
most republicans are and importantly
most republican
voters are still with the guy and it is
very quickly taking an outrageous turn
now i also have to tell you
not only did the things donald trump uh
said raise red flags politically
as you will see he was as incoherent
and as visibly confused as ever
during this speech that he gave and it's
not oh joe biden has a stutter
but he's thinking clearly this is trump
has no stutter
but he seems completely confused by the
things he's saying and what's going on
around him
so this speech was at the north carolina
republican party uh saturday event
here's one example of the incoherence
trump talking about
suspended removals and removable
removals
and looking confused and sweating
profusely and it's all horrible
biden has halted wall construction
suspended removals and even removables
removals of just horrible if biden spoke
like that once it would be 48 hours on
fox news
when joe biden stutters once even though
we know he has a stutter
sean hannity brings in doctors or people
that he just asks medical questions to
even if they're not doctors okay so then
the substance
of sorts and it's still pretty weak as
far as substance goes
trump opening the speech by claiming a
huge success
on the pandemic which has been managed
for the last five months by the joe
biden administration trump talking as if
he's still in power
we've done an incredible job and most
importantly with the vaccine coming up
with it but we've done an incredible job
and
so many things have happened and we
built the economy not once we built it
twice think of it because we built it we
had the highest stock market ever the
best job numbers
and then we had a regroup we had to do a
lot of things we bought
we we became the ventilator factory of
the
world we were making them for everybody
and we had
and our coverage were bare the federal
coverage were there and the state
governments were there
donald trump maybe doesn't understand
verb tense
as well as some of us but he seems to be
talking
like he's still in charge and lots of
the q anon people believe that indeed he
is still in charge
and this just reinforces that thinking
by the way this phrasing that trump uses
we did an incredible job
coming up with the vaccine that really
takes a special
kind of narcissism and delusion we did a
great job coming up with the vaccine
now on pandemic stuff trump is still
calling the 1918 flu the 1917 flu
i don't know why remember we interviewed
a flu historian on the show
an historian and said is there any
reason you could call the 1918 flu the
17 flu he said no there just is no
reason for that
here's trump doing it again you would
have had a 1907
spanish flu number they lost they say
up to 100 million people you would have
had those i guess it's a case of if you
accidentally say it wrong once
if you're a narcissist you just stick
with it for years
because you can't admit that you were
ever wrong about anything
then trump gets into the current
investigations of him
and see if you can even remotely
understand
what he's saying here the radical left
prosecutors go after trump
just give it a shot they say give it a
shot they failed in washington they
failed all over the place
between the impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hooks number two
all of these investigations oh
[ __ ] we failed
let's send it to the radical left
prosecutors in new york
maybe they can have more luck they'll
never stop
until november of 2024 they won't stop
i guess the takeaway is the point is
it's all a hoax trump being very edgy
there
right guys impressive stuff trump then
keeps talking about these investigations
and he simply doesn't
sound well it seems to be getting to him
in some kind of deep way
what did he do well we don't know but
we'll figure it out
washington post reported the other day
they've gotten
millions of pages of documents well when
did he do a deal oh did he do another
deal did
they go through every deal every deal
i've ever done millions and millions of
pages if there's a comma
mistake if there's a misspelling
its problems you know what it's a
disgrace to our country
it's prosecutorial misconduct
they're in search of a crime it's a
fishing expedition and the supreme court
of the united states should not have
allowed it to happen
shouldn't have allowed it and they
mentioned it can't be a fishing
expedition this is the ultimate
fishing expedition it's been
a five-year-long witch hunt hoax after
hoax russia russia russia
trump really has a long list of things
that the supreme court should do
i don't know if you've noticed they
should stop the investigations into
trump
they should have given trump the 2020
election he's very disappointed and
what's interesting about this is
if your whole life the way things have
worked is
when i give somebody a job they do me
favors
he probably doesn't understand how could
it be that a supreme court
with three justices on it that he picked
isn't doing exactly what he wants him to
do that's different
than the way donald trump's uh career
has gone so far
and then this next clip really takes
some gall after obstructing
an investigation into himself and
trying to steal the election and
inciting an insurrection
trump has the audacity to say he
is trying to save democracy
remember i am not the one trying to
undermine
american democracy i'm the one that's
trying to save it please remember that
the opposite is true of course donald
trump one of the biggest
threats to american democracy as we know
it
so there it is i mean a completely vapid
and low energy speech trump confused
trump sweating trump lying but the crowd
mostly loved it and it is so clear you
know we've been wondering for a few
months what direction is this party
going to go
it's abundantly clear this guy controls
the party overall right now
not everyone is on his side many
individuals don't like him especially
privately but officially
this is clearly still the party of
donald trump at this point in time
and just you wait to see what else we're
going to look at today
that this guy was involved in over the
weekend
it was not just a speech in north
carolina that former president donald
trump
gave this weekend donald trump in his
speech
made it clear he's going to be the
decider for republicans
in 2022 he will say who is okay to
reelect or to vote for
and who is not who is a republican in
name only or someone who has abandoned
the party
as far as trump is concerned but trump
also recorded
a republican fundraising video and he is
once again talking about
we're going to take back the white house
sooner
than you think now i know that in the
absence of
any other data points hearing trump say
we're going to take back the white house
sooner than you think
it might not have any real meaning that
might not mean anything to us
but when trump says it you have to
understand the context
trump is suggesting he will be back in
the white house
before january of 2025.
a normal person who hears a former
president say
we will take back the white house that
would mean to you
at the next presidential election
november of 2024
but the addition of sooner than you
think
means exactly what donald trump has been
telling people according to both maggie
haberman from the new york times
and the right wing national review which
is he is going to be back in power
sooner than when he could be by winning
in november of 2024. here's the clip
from this bizarre trump fundraising
video i want to thank
everybody for the tremendous support
you've shown we're going to take back
the senate take back the house we're
going to take back the white house and
sooner than you think it's going to be
really something special but
we're going to take back the white house
sooner than you think trump is again
talking about somehow getting
biden out before his term is up and
getting back in
uh before joe biden's term is up now i
really hope
that people understand even if for any
reason joe biden did not complete his
term
kamala harris becomes the president not
donald trump
they don't say well for some reason
biden is out
let's go back to the last guy or the one
before that or the one before that
that's not how it works it goes to the
vice president
so aside from the aspects of this that
relate to
this being the same type of rhetoric
again
that eventually led to the january 6
riots
we'll discuss that more probably
tomorrow this is a complete fantasy
world
understanding or misunderstanding better
said
of how our government works the video
was posted to the youtube channel of the
national
republican senatorial committee the nrsc
the uh senate republican fundraising arm
is what that is and it was posted friday
it's not exactly clear when it was
recorded but it shows
trump floating similar ideas to what
he's reportedly been saying
in private that somehow this guy is
going to be reinstated as president now
by itself
it might just sound like a weirdly uh a
weirdly phrased
thing to say but then the new york times
the washington post the national review
are all reporting that donald trump
believes this bizarre
election audit or audits that are going
on are somehow going to put him back in
power
at some point isn't this seditious by
donald trump
isn't this all pushing and pointing
towards rebellion against the
established authority of the united
states
the current government shouldn't someone
go to the nrsc
or the north carolina republican party
or whoever where trump has been saying
this stuff
and say what exactly does sooner than
you think mean
because that's really the question right
now what do you believe
sir is the soonest possible date at
which donald trump could again be
president
if the answer is anything other than
january of 2025 when the next president
is inaugurated
then you know you're dealing with a
wacky person and as these new trump
rallies start up again
i would love to see this asked of the
attendees
people that are there what do you think
is the soonest that donald trump could
again be president and if they say
anything
other than january of 2025 it will give
you a real sense
of where the electorate is at this point
in time so
a wacky bizarre and deranged weekend
and we're going to have more about the
implications of this a little bit later
on in the program
i will talk about dr fauci's emails i am
going to talk about joe manchin
it's a packed show i'm glad you're here
and you can find me on twitter for any
story requests
commentary or uh trolling uh at
deepakman we'll take a quick break
and be right back
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to
blinkist.com slash david pakman i've put
the link
right underneath this video remember
that the david pakman show is sponsored
primarily by viewers like you through
the david pakman show membership program
you can grab
a membership at joinpacman.com coupon
code
available and never mandatory that code
is better21
you'll get instant access to the daily
bonus show the commercial free audio
and video streams of the show and so
many other great things and you'll be
supporting the show that's that's the
really
key thing uh sign up today at
joinpacman.com
so um when joe biden won in november
we started a conversation about what
will joe biden be able to get done what
will be the parameters and the limits of
what joe biden can do
and i made the case that joe manchin
the democratic senator from west
virginia who
is arguably the most right wing of the
democratic senators
was really going to be a problem was
really going to be an impediment was
really going to be a major obstacle and
some people in the audience got it
but many wrote to me and said david i
think you're overstating the case about
joe manchin
here and i maintained no i'm not no i
believe that joe manchin really is going
to be
this big of a problem and we are now
learning just how big of a
problem joe manchin is going to be cnn
reports
democratic senator joe manchin on sunday
yesterday defended his decision to vote
against a sweeping voting rights bill
and reiterated his opposition to gutting
the filibuster declaring
in the strongest terms yet that he is
not willing
to change senate rules to help his party
push through much of joe
biden's agenda mansion said they call
him a moderate democrat which is a very
favorable term
manchin said quote i believe that
partisan voting legislation will destroy
the already weakening binds of our
democracy and for that reason i will
vote against
the for the people act further i will
not vote to weaken or eliminate the
filibuster this is what's so
sick about this position it's basically
a both sides
type position what i mean by that is
joe manchin is saying well if i
am going to do voting rights legislation
i don't want it to be
partisan or one-sided but the problem is
that the other side the republican party
is using disenfranchisement as a tool
to try to win elections joe manchin
seems to think and maybe he believes it
or maybe he's just saying it
that if one side wants to pass partisan
legislation to prevent people from being
able to legally vote
and the other side wants to pass
legislation to ensure
everyone who's entitled to vote can vote
they're both
simply partisan voting rights
pieces of legislation this is it's hard
to imagine
a more depraved sort of both sides
type argument and this is exactly
what i feared would happen with joe
manchin
and it is indeed happening huffington
post is also
reporting about this saying that senator
joe manchin said he won't vote
for his parties for the people act a
bill focused on expanding voting rights
again the idea that
limiting voting rights which is against
the constitution against the law against
what this country is built on
and expanding voting rights for people
who can legally vote
are just two sides of the same political
coin
that is the full end position
toxicity level of the idea of the
enlightened centrist and
i'm not going to be super partisan on
either side when one side is trying to
take rights away you can't say well
i don't want to get involved on this
side either because we're just as
partisan in trying to make sure people
have their rights that's not the way it
works
and this is the sort of you know i use
the term enlightened centrism
sometimes to refer to online
commentators or whatever who want to
pretend to kind of be above the partisan
fray
and see both sides what this is one of
100 members of the us senate
who is equating taking voting rights
away
as a partisan act by republicans to
giving voting rights as a partisan act
by democrats when the reality is
what the constitution says and what the
law says should be the guiding principle
here so it's
truly unbelievable and disgusting uh
kirsten cinema
on the democratic side also arguably a
problem
uh in in some areas and we'll ultimately
see what happens
with this uh for for the people act but
this does not look
good now i i know that many people will
say well david then
let's primary joe manchin i'm not
against primarying anybody as i've said
before
primary whoever the hell you want simply
understand
what the consequences of that might be i
don't see
how a more progressive democrat wins in
west virginia
my instinct is based on the pew polling
data i've seen out of west virginia
that if you successfully primary joe
mansion
with a more progressive democrat which i
don't even know if
if one would win but if joe manchin
loses a democratic primary to a more
progressive democrat
it seems almost certain that that more
progressive democrat
loses the eventual general election and
then you have
a republican in that seat so obviously
this is disgusting
obviously i find all of this completely
disgusting and counterproductive and
retrograde and
it's exactly what we predicted in
november was going to happen so i'm not
surprised by it
but mansion still mostly votes for
democrats so i'm not
defending the guy i'm merely saying
you're playing with fire if what you
might
do to fix the joe mansion problem
loses democrats the majority
in the senate now of course there will
be other races as well when joe manchin
is up so it's more complicated than that
but i'm i'm curious to hear from you
about it because it's not at all clear
to me
that the win the way to win this is by
removing mansion and putting at risk
that seat
maybe being taken over by a republican i
would be
you know uh my instinct is biden talks
about how great a negotiator he is well
negotiate with this guy
biden brags about negotiating across the
aisle negotiate with your own side
to get this guy on board if you're
really the great diplomat and negotiator
you claim to be
and in some senses joe biden is a good
negotiator he's done
some some good things negotiating then
convince this guy
what are we waiting for that i think we
need to find a way
to push mansion into supporting at least
some of this stuff
uh because the risk of losing him to a
republican in that seat
to me seems great i'm curious
the risk is great it's not a good thing
to be clear
um let me know what you think i want to
hear from you about it you know um
last summer when
we started with the george floyd
protests and we started with the police
accountability movement
some were in the defund the police
movement that wasn't me i was part of
the
police accountability and reform
movement
we started hearing from all sorts of
corporations
we will be mandating all of our managers
do
implicit bias training and at the time i
said and i've continued to say
to me that really is actual virtue
signaling
it's actual pr it's actual optics
and there were two reasons i had for
believing that
number one many of the corporations that
were very loudly saying we're gonna do
implicit bias training
um also had histories of donations
to political candidates that didn't
really subscribe
to the belief of holding police
accountable and dealing with uh
racism in this country etc um and
number two the the other critique i had
of the implicit bias trainings was that
it's not at all clear to me
that training managers at starbucks or
whatever
is really what's going to get at the
root of the problem in the united states
okay that was my criticism then
we now have part two of this as many of
you may know we are now in pride month
here in the united states pride month
where we um
uh uh celebrate and and respect
inclusivity with the uh with regard to
the lgbt community i don't know exactly
what pride
how they name pride month i'm just sort
of making this up as i go along
but it's a month about recognizing
diversity and the importance of equality
and respect and etc
and you have companies and this is
there's a great report on this in
business insider you've got walmart
you've got mcdonald's you've got amazon
celebrating pride
after donating hundreds of thousands of
dollars to politicians who voted against
the equality act uh the same
these same three companies amazon
walmart and mcdonald's
collectively donated more than one
million dollars to lawmakers
who voted against the equality act now
in february
the vast majority of republicans in the
house of representatives
voted against the equality act the
equality act was
the goal was to expand lgbtq protections
and if you look at sec filings you will
see that
a lot of the best known companies in the
united states and that includes the ones
i mentioned
donated a whole bunch of money to
politicians who voted against the bill
now most companies donate to both
political parties you look at you know
comcast you look at these big isps
you look at a lot of the big social
media platforms you look at all of it
most of them are donating to both sides
why well it's sort of obvious you don't
know
as a corporation which way the political
wins are going to go
you could get involved and try to get if
you think democrats are better for your
business you could say let's try to get
democrats involved only but then what if
it doesn't happen
you're in a pretty awkward position as a
company that wants to
affect lobbying and legislative power
over members of congress etc so
you just donate to both sides and then
whoever wins wins and then you've got
hopefully friends regardless
and this is exactly what is going on
here and you know i don't mind
i think it's a great thing if from a
marketing perspective
it's better to be pro-equality than
anti-equality right like
put the money out of it for a second if
you just say to me
would you prefer a country in which
saying
we celebrate pride month is good for
business
rather than a country in which saying no
gays allowed
is good for business of course the
country
in which it's more profitable to be for
equality
is the country that i prefer but these
companies
are just doing this for business reasons
in the companies there's no doubt that
you would be able to find
uh homophobic people and people who are
for
lgbt rights and are inclusive and
welcoming and for equality and all of
that
but a corporation one of the things
about it is
that it takes on different dynamics than
simply the sum of the opinions of the
individuals who make it up and this is
how you get corporations
that end up doing completely immoral and
horrible things if you individually talk
to the people
at a lot of these companies and say hey
would you ever
authorize the known pollution of a river
with carcinogenic whatever
it'd be hard to find individuals who say
yeah that would be fine
with me but you end up with a
corporation where roles and
responsibilities are compartmentalized
and
you end up with corporations doing
things or at least looking away as
things are done that individually many
of these people would not do
much the same way you could have
homophobic
and and uh lgbtq inclusive people
at a corporation and of course amazon
does and of course mcdonald's does at
their stores and of course walmart does
there's no doubt about it
but then as a corporation you would say
what is best for the bottom line and
what's best for the bottom line right
now
is you celebrate pride month brazenly
and cynically from the perspective of
what you really believe as a company
but you keep the money flowing to the
anti-gay
elected officials because the tide could
turn and they could end up
in power now um should you consider this
in deciding whether to do business with
walmart or
amazon or mcdonald's i don't know the
answer to that
i don't know the answer to that because
certainly the fact that they're at least
celebrating pride month rather than
taking a homophobic position
is preferable but at the same time if it
really came down to it
and their profits depended only on
anti-gay politicians
then what would your position be what
would their position be on pride month
by the way so i don't know i
i my approach in thinking about what
companies i do business with is
if i'm doing business with a small
business
i do sort of pay attention to you know
if there's three owners there's a
there's restaurants i've found out
have completely xenophobic
owners um and i've stopped going to that
restaurant
with a company like amazon or walmart i
haven't been in a walmart in 15 20 years
or something like that
it's less about the individuals because
there's so many individuals and i think
it's a really personal decision i don't
really have any advice on that but
the exact same cynicism with which i saw
the implicit bias trainings being rolled
out over the summer and into
early early fall last year we're seeing
the exact same thing from these
companies celebrating pride month
while under uh the table or but not
under the table behind the scenes
donating to elected officials who were
disgusted by the concept of pride month
let me know what you think about how you
decide
whether such a company is one that you
want to give your hard-earned dollars to
i'm curious to hear from you
and we'll have more on this on our
instagram account you can find us on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
if you want to see me at the beach over
the weekend
for a break from politics follow me on
instagram
at david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming
a member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show the regular show with
no commercials
you also get access to our entire
archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
okay now this we have to discuss
the newest idea for trump to crowbar his
way back into power
is that he could run for a seat in the
house of representatives
in 2022 and then if he wins
he could try to become the speaker of
the house of representatives and then a
speaker of the house he could then
impeach
joe biden this is something that wayne
allen root
asked donald trump about on his radio
show late last week
wayne allen root has been a guest on
this show a bunch of times
and it's been pretty wacky every time
you can check that out
on our youtube channel if you're
interested and trump seemed interested
in this uh that that it was really an
idea worth considering take a look at
this video
why not instead of just waiting for 2024
and i'm hoping you run
in 2024 but why not why not run in 2022
for the united states congress a house
seat in florida
win big lead us to a dramatic landslide
victory taking the house
by 50 seats and then you become the
speaker of the house
lead the impeachment of biden and start
criminal investigations against biden
you'll
wipe him out for his last two years and
then you'll be president
do it you know it's very interesting
it's so interesting
you'll be a folk hero and people have
said people have said run for the senate
okay run for the senate
but you know what your idea might be
better it's very interesting now this is
actually something that steve bannon
has floated before the idea of trump
running for congress or maybe even
senate but congress
and then figuring out okay now what what
can we do about joe biden bannon spoke
to the
boston republicans back in february and
said trump could
run for the house quote we totally get
rid of nancy pelosi
and the first act of president trump as
speaker
will be to impeach joe biden for his
illegitimate activities
of stealing the presidency so bannon's
already been thinking
along these lines now the funniest part
about this i have to tell you
is that trump could run for speaker of
the house
without being a member of congress i
know this might sound
strange but our friend of the show bill
share pointed this out tweeting quote
why are republicans telling trump he
should run for the house to become
speaker
you don't have to be a house member to
be speaker it's a whole lot easier to
just
demand to be speaker the house
republican party would cancel mccarthy
faster than the dixie chicks now
this is true it's true that you don't
have to be
a member of the house to be speaker of
the house but tradition
does play a big role bill share is
technically right the speaker of the
house in the united states
is not legally required to be an elected
member of the house of representatives
but if you look at the articles of the
confederation which predate the
constitution
it does say that the congress of the
united states has the power
to quote appoint one of their number to
so it doesn't have to be that way just
i could be speaker of the house you
could be speaker of the house without
being a member if the members of the
house
do select you but needless to say
let's not give donald trump this idea i
don't actually expect donald trump to
run for the house
if he did it's certainly plausible that
if he won
and republicans took the house in 2022
you could maybe see republicans choose
donald trump
as speaker of the house but the funniest
thing for me
there's two really funny things about
this for me one
if trump hated being president because
everybody kept asking him to do stuff
when he just wanted to watch
tv he would despise
being a member of the house you actually
sort of have to do
some more stuff than as president if
you're a member of the house you're
expected to show up in your district and
do some constituent work although
you know maybe if it's trump he wouldn't
be expected to do that that's number one
that's funny
but then the really funny thing is this
idea
conflicts with trump being back in power
in august
in other words why would trump run for
house of representatives
in november of 2022 if he's going to be
president again
in august of 2021 as is now being widely
reported that he believes
the one way that this could backfire
is if trump decides to run for a house
seat
especially on a plan of becoming house
speaker
and it does seem to me that it could
backfire
in that if trump's running for the house
i think democrats get really active
we've been talking about who is going to
be able to get the vote out in the
upcoming 2022 midterms
and in general it's not good for the
party that takes over the white house
partially
because they are sort of uh happy and
satisfied that they've taken over the
white house two years later they tend to
stay home
more than the opposite party so that
favors republicans
if trump's running for the house i think
it reinvigorates democrats and democrats
come out and vote vote vote in 2022
in a way that would probably not be so
good for republicans that's just my
thought
let me know what you think and tell me
if you agree that trump would absolutely
hate being a member of the house all
right so now we're going to wrap
up the entire trump portion of the show
this is a really important update on a
story
from last week last week you might
remember that the new york times's
maggie haberman
uh tweeted an absolutely outrageous
story
which was that donald trump has been
telling people around him that he
believes he's going to be reinstated to
the white house
uh as soon as august of this year now as
a reminder
haberman tweeted quote trump has been
telling a number of people he's in
contact with that he expects he will be
reinstated by august
no that isn't how it works but simply
sharing the information
going on to say that it isn't happening
in a vacuum
it is happening as he faced the
possibility of an indictment
from the manhattan district attorney and
then lastly adding that quote he is not
putting out statements about the audits
in states
just for the sake of it he's been laser
focused on them
according to several people who've
spoken with him as well as
washington post reporting a few weeks
ago
now when this story broke last week a
whole bunch of people
started immediately calling it fake news
and
trump's blog right before it shut down
also had a post where donald trump was
denying it but
since then the story has been
corroborated
and the truth as it often is with trump
is even crazier than the reality the
right
wing national review not a left-wing
bomb-throwing
uh uh publication not a publication that
trump has been calling fake news
the right wing national review published
a story called
maggie haberman is right which actually
tells an even crazier story reporting
that it's not only trump
who thinks he's going to be reinstated
it's trump and
to republican senators as well charles
cook writes in the piece
quote instead they should have listened
because haberman's reporting was correct
i can attest from speaking to an array
of different sources
that donald trump does indeed believe
quite genuinely that he
along with former senators david perdue
and martha mcsally
will be reinstated to office this summer
after audits of the 2020 elections in
arizona
georgia and a handful of other states
have been completed i can attest too
that trump is trying hard to recruit
journalists politicians and other
influential figures
to promulgate this belief not as a
fundraising tool
or an infantile bit of trolling or a
trial balloon
but as a fact this
is nuts my friends and the article goes
on to say and remember this is the
conservative national review saying this
the article goes on to say
the scale of trump's delusion is quite
startling
this is not merely an eccentric
interpretation of the facts
or an interesting foible nor is it an
irrelevant
example of anguished post-presidency
chatter it is a rejection of reality
a rejection of law and ultimately a
rejection of the entire system of
american government there is no
reinstatement clause
within the united states constitution
hell there is nothing even approximating
a reinstatement clause
within the united states constitution
the
election has been certified joe biden is
the president
and until 2024 that is all there is to
it doesn't matter what one's view of
trump is
doesn't matter whether one voted for or
against trump it doesn't matter whether
one's view
one views trump's role within the
republican party favorably or
unfavorably
we are talking here about cold hard
neutral facts
that obtain irrespective of one's
preferences
it is not too much to ask that the
former head of the executive branch
should understand them this is why i
said earlier in the show
a new litmus test a sort of a gut
check sanity check question to right
wingers
should be going forward what is the
soonest
you believe donald trump could again be
president trump says he's going to be
restarting rallies as soon as this month
send reporters to the rallies and say to
them sir
ma'am what is the soonest you believe
donald trump could be president and if
it's
any earlier than january of 2025
it's someone either living in a fantasy
world or someone very very ignorant
so not only was maggie haberman correct
in her reporting
not only has that been corroborated it
is not trump alone
but also david perdue and martha mcsally
who believe
i guess that they're going to be
reinstated to their senate seats
somehow sometime during this summer
these are really dangerous times
especially because and we'll talk about
this tomorrow
when this stuff inevitably doesn't
happen
will the trump acolytes again be moved
to real world violence and destruction
of property
and breaking and entering and
trespassing and violence that we saw on
january 6th
that's the really scary part and we'll
probably talk more about that
tomorrow
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show so we have an example
today of something i've been talking
about with you guys for a long time
one of the hallmarks of conspiratorial
thinking
is that finding apparent evidence is of
course
evidence of the conspiracy a conspiracy
theory
but not finding evidence is also
evidence of the conspiracy because it
means that
they covered up the evidence the
evidence has been destroyed
the evidence has been suppressed and so
there's really no way out of these
conspiracy thinking situations we now
have an example of this from the world
of covid's conspiracies you really have
to see this
uh the tick tock channel the good liars
interviewed a woman
who claims that her friend who
supposedly died of covid which is a
tragedy
was actually medically abducted
and killed so that the hospital could
get
fifty thousand dollars for treating a
fake
covet patient this is a woman who has a
friend
the friend tragically got the virus and
died
that's evidence that her conspiracy
about covid being
a hoax is wrong it would seem as though
the evidence disproves
the covet hoax conspiracy that this
woman believes
nope the fact that her friend died of
kovid
becomes part of the conspiracy the
evidence was faked
she was abducted her friend didn't
really die
of covid so let's look at the full clip
once then we're going to look back at
some individual pieces because
there's just so much here another friend
of mine she actually was
medically kidnapped they did it to get
the money for fifty thousand dollars
because if you say you have covered you
get fifty thousand dollars to hospitals
but she died of covet in the hospital
she didn't die of covered they killed
her
but she was she she tested positive for
code no she was just she got she
she just passed out because she was weak
this one day i have a picture of her
they have her mouth and they have her
sedated they have her on that ventilator
okay so of course this is all horribly
tragic a death from covet is tragic
but also this woman believing that this
is what happened
is is tragic as well so let's dig into
just how much stuff is wrong
about what she says because it's
actually remarkable how much is squeezed
into just 21 seconds here let's look at
the first bit again
another friend of mine she actually was
medically kidnapped they did it to get
the money for fifty thousand dollars
because if you say you have covered you
get fifty thousand dollars the hospital
okay so there's this idea if a hospital
says someone has covered
they get fifty thousand dollars for
treating them
this all goes back to when medicare
rates were established for covid19
patients
who don't need to be put on a ventilator
and who do need to be put on a
ventilator
it turned out that the reimbursement
rates for medicare patients were a
little bit higher
uh than for non-covered hospitalizations
there's a reason for that and there's
also no evidence whatsoever of
fraudulent reporting
and the other funny thing is the num the
numbers started at 35 000 for covid
patients
now that apparently wasn't wacky enough
so now they go to it's 50
000 for a covid patient medicare
establishes reimbursement rates for
treatment
it is true that if a patient goes on a
ventilator
medicare reimburses more than if they
don't because they're providing more
services
it is true that for covet patients on
ventilators
medicare reimburses a little bit more
because remember the way health
insurance works is on
averages on average it is more expensive
to treat the coveted patient that is on
a ventilator now we can have an argument
about how our medical system works
how it works where doctors and hospitals
get paid for each thing
that they do rather than simply for
keeping people healthy or making people
healthy
that's all fine but the issue here is
hospitals don't just get cash for
claiming people
have a covid and there is no evidence
whatsoever that hospitals are lying
about it there is no evidence hospitals
are lying about it they are simply being
compensated
based on the services that they provide
this is really
nutty stuff let's look at the rest of it
but she
died of covert in the hospital they
killed her but she was she she tested
positive for covet no she was just she
got
she just passed out because she was weak
this one day i have a picture of her
they have her mouth and they have her
sedated they have her on that ventilator
imagine that story her friend was fine
and then one day her friend passes out
because she was weak that day it was
just a weak day the friend passed out
nothing was wrong with her just a week
day
and in swoops a hospital abducts her
reports her as having covid to get the
50k
and then kills her and this brings me to
one other aspect of this that's really
really wild
you don't need the patient to die to get
paid
if you treat them at the hospital you
get paid for the treatment you provide
you don't get more money because they
die
and the conspiracy theorists would say
well no david
please the reason you have to kill them
is because otherwise they could go and
say
i didn't really have covid they
kidnapped me or whatever
but now there's a new conspiracy right
you're adding layers of complexity to
the conspiracy that was another wacky
part of it uh this is serious illness
i'm talking about what the woman that
that survived has that is serious
illness
and unfortunately how on earth do you
talk sense into someone like that you
know there are some conspiracy theorists
that when you talk to them you sort of
get the feeling
maybe i'd be able to talk some sense
into them we might be able to have
like a real conversation and over time
they might be able to be
disabused and deprogrammed of these
beliefs
i don't know how you could with this
woman i really don't
and of course the idea of hospitals
over counting for cash happens to be
something trump floated
in 2020. trump talked about hospitals or
lying about this to make money
so there's always some trump connection
and certainly i would assume
that this woman voted for donald trump
this is really bad stuff this is
to call it weaponized delusions uh
i don't think goes far enough and i
don't know how we deal with that if you
have any ideas let me know
i want to talk a little bit about the dr
anthony fauci
email story and the reason i haven't
spoken about it yet
is because i don't see it as much of a
story
but i received a few emails over the
weekend from people saying david what do
you think
about the fouchy emails so let's talk
about it a little bit today
last week the washington post as well as
buzzfeed news
published a bunch of emails in which dr
anthony fauci is either the recipient
the sender or
both involved in a back and forth and
these are from relatively early in the
pandemic
february march april and the emails were
obtained through a foia request
and since these emails were released all
sorts of conservatives
and right-wing media have been saying
wow these emails
are the smoking gun about the misdeeds
of dr anthony fauci rand paul was
talking about these emails proving
fouchy needs to be removed and it has
become a big story among the right
now i've looked at these emails not all
of them because there's 900 pages of
emails but i've looked at the emails
that
the right wingers believe are the
smoking gun
and the reason i haven't talked about it
is i can't find a smoking gun here
one aspect of the emails is the
the so-called lab leak theory and the
idea
from the right is the emails prove
that privately dr fauci was
acknowledging this could have come from
a lab this might be man-made
could have come from a chinese lab even
though publicly dr
fauci was not saying that at the time
that's the claim from the right
i looked at the emails related to this
you can look at them as well
to me it only shows that dr fauci seemed
open to people investigating this as he
remains today but he didn't believe at
the time
that the evidence pointed in that
direction no such evidence had been
presented to him
and eventually you look in the emails he
gets emails from others who start to
agree
for example the immunologist christian
anderson who said hey we should maybe
look at this
and later emails fauci and says it's
extremely unlikely
that the lab leak theory is the right
one it just
isn't compelling evidence that what dr
fauci believed
at the time was that the lab leak was
likely and that he was lying publicly
i just couldn't find evidence of that by
looking at the emails
second point of controversy from the
fouchy emails has been
that initially dr fauci downplayed the
need
for the general public to wear masks
even though eventually as
as we know most people started wearing
masks even if you weren't sick
now this has already been sort of
litigated in the media
and dr fauci has since acknowledged the
reason for those initial statements was
in great part motivated by wanting to
prevent
a run on masks which would then deprive
health workers of the masks combined
with at the time they really didn't
think anybody who was
who was not sick needed to wear them to
me the emails showed
that dr fauci at least into february
was privately saying the same thing he
was saying publicly which is if you're
not sick you don't need to wear a mask
so
i do think there's a fair criticism of
dr fauci for the mask stuff
but it's been done there's nothing new
based on the emails
he's admitted to why he
said what he said and the emails don't
change that so
i didn't find a story there either other
storylines from the emails include
the idea of some kind of offer from mark
zuckerberg to dr fauci some right
wingers including laura ingraham
have focused on this saying what exactly
was that offer
um it appears that what it was was an
offer from mark zuckerberg
to work with thauchi's team to tamp down
on
disinformation about coronavirus on
facebook that's what it seems to be
the least charitable way to interpret
that
would be that they were colluding to
censor people um
but the offer was about apparently
tamping down on coronavirus
disinformation not a big smoking gun
and then the other topic is
hydroxychloroquine
the right has been claiming that
privately
as evidenced by these emails dr fauci
knew that hydroxychloroquine could
really work on kovid
but publicly fouchy was saying it
doesn't work the reality is
neither claim is true the emails don't
show
that fauci thought it was a treatment
that worked for kovid
and publicly remember all fauci was
saying was
we don't yet have evidence from
double-blind
randomly controlled trials that would
suggest to us that
hydroxychloroquine is a good treatment
for coronavirus prophylactically
or in an acute sense that's what he was
saying publicly
and there is nothing in the these emails
that contradicts that so
that's my assessment of the main
controversies related to these emails it
is those four
lab leak uh masks um
hydroxychloroquine um as well as
the um uh what uh masks
hydroxychloroquine
mass hydroxychloroquine now i'm not even
looking at my notes here
censoring oh and yes and the uh the the
facebook thing barely even rates because
it's so bizarre
those were the four controversies i
found and
none of them seemed like a smoking gun
so if i've missed a controversy
for which these emails are the smoking
gun
let me know if you disagree with my
assessment of any of these four
topics let me know as well i'm glad to
revisit i am just not seeing it
we have a voicemail number and that
number is
219 to david p
here is a voicemail i got from someone
brutally calling me out
for things they maybe misunderstood
let's take a listen
david i'm a member this is tim from
california i am
outraged because you said that
plumbers make 40 000 per year
no try like i don't know i think they
make like a hundred thousand
no no no no no so what i i referenced
joe the plumber joe the plumber was
known
for during the 2008 election between
barack obama and the late senator john
mccain
coming out and saying plumbers like me
are going to end up paying a lot more in
taxes under barack obama's plan
and framed in that was the idea that he
had a plumbing business from which he
made
250 000 a year because
if he didn't make 250 000 a year he
wasn't going to pay any more under
barack obama's plan
we later found out he didn't even own
that he was like thinking of buying the
plumbing business or something like that
and he made far less money so i didn't
mean to suggest plumbers make 40 grand
when i specifically said joe the plumber
the point was
he didn't make 250 000 he wasn't going
to be subject to more tax under obama
and he wouldn't be subject to more
attacks
uh under under joe biden that was the
point let's
google continue and bill nye isn't a
scientist
he's technically a mechanical engineer
an actor and i mean i love bill nye but
he's um
he shouldn't be called a scientist
technically when did i last even mention
bill nye i don't even know why someone's
coming to me with bill
did i mention bill nye and just forget
it's very strange in any case
you can call the voicemail number
anytime you want 219
to david p i prefer that you comment on
things
i've actually said very often the
right-wing trolls call in
and attack me brutally for things they
must have heard on some other show
because they're certainly not things i
talked about i don't know but 2192 david
p
is that number we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today
uh the aclu is facing a sort of identity
crisis
it was at one point simply known as the
bastion of free speech
but the aclu has been in some weird
situations lately i have a personal
story to mention about this that i'll
tell you guys about that's on today's
bonus show
california has approved a pilot program
for driverless vehicles driverless rides
and many people are excited others are
going completely crazy as if the sky
were falling we will talk about
that on today's bonus show and also the
fda has approved
an obesity drug that has helped some
people drop a significant amount of
weight
but there are some who believe that it
is not a fair
drug it is not a fair drug because it
could allow people
to have an unhealthy lifestyle and diet
and still lose weight and under the
paradigm of strict father morality that
would be
wrong very very wrong so we'll talk
about that on today's bonus show as well
get instant access to the bonus show by
signing up for a membership
at joinedpakman.com or make a patreon
pledge
at patreon.com davidpackingshow
i will speak to you then
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman